could he sponsor me how give you money
just shout like why because I need money
maybe I could just give you money
there's 10 bucks there's another 10
bucks there's a hundred bucks
can I tell you something yeah earning
feels a lot better than just being
given it how old are you ten like that
120 at 10 you're excited but I promise
you when you get 15 you get 20 you'll
feel better that you actually made it
yourself versus some random guy gave it
to you if you get into the habit of just
trying to get it quick and short without
you actually earning it you're never
gonna get what the you want
I did trade attention and build
businesses
Legacy is greater than currency
like documented
the V friends booth has been popping for
the last three days with tonight being
the night of the big CNC tournament
we're showing you more of the game
here's Gary to explain how this all
started let's start
let's start in 2018 I was gonna make a
toy called workplace Warriors because I
got so many DMS for people that were
miserable at work and they hate their
boss they hate their co-workers they
hate their job this is up then I
noticed when I would go to the bathroom
in the office like every single desk had
Simpsons toys Marvel toys Disney
toys I've always been fascinated by IP
and pop culture I was like you know what
I'm gonna make some toys called
workplace Warriors to cheer people up I
got busy and then covet hit so it sat on
the show then nfts come out I'm like
you know what I'm gonna bring back
that workplace Warriors idea got to work
started thinking and then I came up with
the defense concept which is strangers
become acquaintances
acquaintances become friends friends
become family I'm really a Sesame Street
meets Pokemon if I'm being to the point
as I can be so I launched this two years
ago created these characters originally
I drew them now they've been converted
into this character form that you see
created a TCG doing animation and trying
to build a really cool non-sports car
brand and I'm really enjoying it now
back to the show
foreign
[Music]
he made me a little Pudge I'm a little
bit upset about that but I do fluctuate
all right all right here we go this is
for Chad Chad come on
holy that's the best core Decor
back to back the best three colors I've
ever seen ever
just launched the official rules wearing
our first beta tournament tonight 52
competitors we're excited about it is
there a character for you that
disability speaks to you the most
accountable Aunt I think accountability
is the biggest issue in our society
right now we've gotten very good at
pointing fingers that it's everybody
else's fault and so I think if I can
make people fall in love with the
countable and then I can make people
fall in love with accountability and I
think a lot of people can get out of
Dark Places once they realize they're in
control
thank you
[Music]
that guy's not showing up tomorrow he
went to Fisheries know a long time says
you want the booth first said I'll take
it but then fish came to me and said you
take it you set up six tables we're
gonna do the game what are these for
tonight
there's 52 contestants for being
collected tonight and they're all
getting this sandwich whoever wins
tonight's tournament
the single most valuable defense card of
all time let's see the other one we're
gonna do is I'm gonna eat it do it
I'm kidding I'm kidding oh come on
I had some very dark times and when I
started listening to you I got a whole
different mindset of how lucky I am to
just be here period And I needed you to
tell me face what what do I need to do
to keep growing my YouTube channel
because I have a YouTube channel but I
still haven't gotten how much effort do
you put in your thumbnails your titles
your first three seconds there's craft
to this I need to do more studies of how
yeah now go do the push-ups I just
needed you to tell me you got it brother
thank you stay well
on my desk it makes me happy and then
how Full Circle that is for me do you
know that the original the friends was
going to be called workplace Warriors
and it was to have people put these
characters on their desk so you look at
it and you think about I need to be
appreciate with that person right now
right so I love that this sits on your
desk that means a lot to me
no worries I just know you have three
point
five million subscribers on YouTube
that's right could he sponsor me sponsor
you yeah I have a YouTube channel how
give you money just shout like why
because I need money maybe I could just
give you money
sure there's 10 bucks there's another 10
bucks there's a hundred bucks
thank you can I tell you something yeah
earning feels a lot better than
just being given it how old are you ten
like that 120 at 10 you're excited but I
promise you when you get 15 you get 20
you'll feel better that you actually
made it yourself versus some random guy
I gave it to you you need to go out and
earn your subscribers instead of
somebody just giving it to you if you
get into the habit of just trying to get
it quick and short without you actually
earning it you're never gonna get what
the you want
you understand yes so now you need to
start thinking about how do you make
videos that are actually good that
people want to watch instead of hoping
Mr Beast or clicks gives you a shout out
and you win a lottery ticket go out and
earn it my man it will taste
better you're gonna waste that 120
because it came easy but if you earned
it you would have bought smart give me a
hug get in here
you understand that learn that lesson my
dude what's your YouTube channel
it's Gary vaynerchuk
I know you won't remember that yeah but
don't worry one day you will know thank
you you're welcome
hey let's shut it down guys we gotta
shut it down we got a tournament tonight
we gotta go good luck here we are man
here we are
going to win
me killing me I want to play so
bad
welcome to the inaugural compete and
collect tournament
feels incredibly special at night I
think we will all remember I'm extremely
excited for the winner especially with
what they're getting but we're going
into a tournament now this is serious
and good luck
is mine
you guys are asking I came in here and
you've got annihilated it wasn't even
close wow that means you're gonna get
more into it but how are you feeling
right now confident or concerned
confident how are you feeling double
confidence I like it
rips early into the tournament what are
you feeling right now people are
strategic it's not so simple when you
got a good cards it's about getting into
Bluff first time that people are playing
cards
well speaking of my contacts somebody
came prepared there will be no seeing
the eyes of this man people are learning
a lot of people that lost have already
realized their mistakes and they're
chomping to play again that's a good
sign for a game absolutely I think we're
having a good first tournament with a
lot of our original OG family members
which makes me happy I'm excited for the
winner we've got some good players
Dalton you were the worst player even
though you were the elite eight that is
true he's very upset that is the face of
a man who was in the elite eight and
feels like he should be in the final
four
oh foreign
[Applause]
aware of what Tournament winning cards
and things of that nature trophy cards
trophy cards we're so thrilled to be
able to make this for you braided I'm
just so excited all of you have this and
I hope you hold on to it and cherish it
52 of those remain what we're about to
tell you there was only one made up the
biggest moment in the history of be
friends trading cards happen today when
this card came back to us graded in a
manner that we did not expect the first
ever
be friends
and it's a CTC Black Label
it's time to play Rock Paper Scissors
five minutes later oh my God
[Applause]
what happened there in the finals it was
pretty quick when I saw that Phoenix
when I saw that Phoenix I was like odds
are he doesn't have over a 108. so but I
tell you what every one of these I
thought I was going to lose every single
one of these coming into it how many
boxes
I've collected you
did you journey to this set yep 107.
how many autos
[Applause]
one I have good news for you my friend
you didn't pull that auto that auto was
earned
yeah
we just started this this was the first
tournament let's go this game is
that new we have a first champion
[Applause]
what a day we did a tournament our first
ever in series two be friends with the
nft just like in series one where I did
B con I wanted to have a physical item
something real tangible mixing the web 3
world and the web 2 or the analog world
we gave people cards here we are 15
months later so and we've now really
started the process of the vision we had
back then of turning that card not only
to be a collectible but to be a TCG
Trading Card Game
our first beta tournament today it went
extremely well I am documenting the
building of a brand from scratch one
that millions of millions and millions
of people will know and so it's gonna be
a lot of fun I'm going to speak to my 85
year old self right now because he's
gonna be watching this
fun days you love the dirt you're from
the dirt I hope you're at a flea market
right now in the VR environment finding
a three dollar item from b-flash to sell
nine dollars on whatever is the eBay
of the day I know you won't change
say to you don't change they don't know
you you're not thinking
I'm proud of you
that was me is that me that was cool